12 12 okay so I'm really here today to
introduce the children's book that I'm
writing about virtual machines and help
you wake up with some simple JavaScript
code well maybe not so my name is slow
and I'm a compiler engineer at Google
and I'm usually thinking about compiling
various languages into the various other
native languages native code but today I
will be talking about compiling other
languages in two languages the backyard
compiled to native code a very simple
stuff so and i will be using the small
talk as a first language that gets
compiled to something because i like the
small talk it's an awesome language and
I heard it's very easy to compile to
JavaScript if you put enough regular
expressions into your compiler and it is
so amazing this power of regular
expressions to get a very tight output
from your compiler which she looks
almost like something that the normal
JavaScript programmer would write and of
course it has zero overhead i'm planning
to patent it as soon as they return home
so however there is a small problem here
if i try to run this program in
Smalltalk trying to compute a dot
product of a 10 and the vector i get an
error actually because the 10 does not
understand the message x and in
JavaScript I get not a number everybody
likes not a number in JavaScript so and
this problem really repeats itself again
and again when people release compilers
for different languages into JavaScript
because they forget about one very small
detail it's called semantic in German
and this word comes from a Greek word
everybody can read Greek which actually
means significant and how would we call
compiler that forgets a significant
thing about the source language we call
this compiler hm so how make a compiler
that is not a xem well there is one easy
way for example in
small talk everything even the binary
operations on numbers are messages that
you send to your objects so you can
instead for using the JavaScript
operators for computing like Sam and
multiplication you just send a message
using this small utility function that
you write called send and this of course
looks a little bit slow if you write it
like that in JavaScript so let's confirm
it by benchmarking and then put in
benchmarking in quotes because I don't
want anybody to call me out on bed
benchmarks in this talk because I'm just
using it to promote my ideas so I'm
cooking the numbers basically but I did
not tell you that please cut it out so I
wrote this small piece of JavaScript
code which just takes a an array of
vectors and then computes some of them
and then computes the length or length
squared of this the resulting vector
using the dot product and it makes no
sense but I like the benchmarks that
make no sense so and then I translated
it to my small talk ified version of
Java Script where everything is replaced
with message sense to object and and
when you see the code on my slides don't
try to read all the code just let it go
into your brain and when you sleep in
tonight you will suddenly have an
Enlightenment what actually went there
King so then I wrote this sent function
that just sends a message to the object
very simple apply slice call arguments
to yeah everybody writes code like that
because it's JavaScript and so cool and
then because I am also kind of evil I
also put some stuff on the number
prototype because i want to send message
plus to the numbers and i want to send
message add to array so i just modified
the prototypes of array and number so
that just works out of the box and then
a benchmark and lo and behold it's only
five thousand times slower than the
baseline version it's actually fine
because that's the speed the JavaScript
used to run just ten years ago so
however the reason for that is simple we
made it too complicated for VA to
optimize there is a single congestion
point in our code through which all the
message sends are going this sent
function and actually wrote it in the
way that cannot
optimized by v8 if I think that I can
get maybe a factor of 10 speed up but it
will not be enough the factor of four
hundred it will still be missing there
so yeah Jovi it cannot do anything it
just calls and calls sent in our hot
loop so does it mean that v8 or does it
mean that the universal vm the
javascript as a universal vm for other
languages is just a Fed live well i
don't believe that because actually
believe that [ __ ] is a superhero that
can save us all it just needs a sidekick
that would help it to solve to save us
all hmm and i was searching for this
sidekick and then i realized that there
is another language in the world which
claims to have a great vm and the
vibrant ecosystem of libraries and so on
and so forth and they have a lot of
languages that compiled to this vm and
people like it and of course this
language is java the what they used to
run different languages human javascript
on the GV m which is originally was a
virtual machine for static statically
typed programming languages like Java
well it was only BM for java so they
introduced this bytecode into the vm
that allows them to have a dynamic
behavior and we can start reading a lot
of text about the invoke dynamic
specification and sooner or later maybe
a week or two in this text will figure
out this invoke dynamic is somehow
related to the call site sing and then
oh there are even more texts describing
what course itís it's truly like java a
lot of text so let me highlight you the
most important part of this text
so we know what variable is in
JavaScript and if we store function into
a variable and then what happens the
behavior of the call of this through
this variable changes as we change the
value that is stored in the variable
basically enlightenment in JavaScript
every invoke is already dynamic so we
don't need this stuff and we can easily
map things from the GBM specification
into the javascript cause i think that
the heaven java is just a variable the
invoke dynamic instruction is just an
invocation through that variable method
Kendall thing that is actually stored in
the call site in Java is just a closure
and relinking action that happens when
you change the target of the call side
is just an operator equals done so let's
use it to make our code run with a speed
of I don't know sick elephant or
actually healthy elephant so we used to
have this edition in my micro benchmark
somewhere I did not sure where but
believe me it was there so and then I
rewrote it in a nice and tight way with
a small talk sense and now we are doing
the invoke dynamic thing for each sent
that will use to send like st. X colon
we just introduce a special global
variable which will be specialized for
this scent and so on so forth for each
sent in the program and of course we
could initialize them in this simple way
but this will not give us any
performance right we're just doing the
same stuff that we used to do and we
know it's a 5,000 times slower so what
we are going to do instead will be more
Java like and use object-oriented
programming to solve other issues we
introduced the thing that encapsulates
the management of the of this global
variable it knows which message we want
to send through this global variable and
then it also knows how to produce the
small closure and patch it into this
global variable so there is a lot of
code here it actually does that and I
don't want you to read all of it as I
said so let me highlight the most
important part so this bootstrapping
procedure for this global variable it
consists of the compilation of handlers
that will handle this send side and then
we just linked it into the call side so
a compilation is Lou to a lot of black
voodoo magic it has to string on the
function and then users
load a show on the score doesn't matter
so what it essentially does it plays a
little bit of PHP with your source code
so it takes some things and splices them
into the source code like for example
here you can splice the list of
arguments into the function and then you
can splice the operation that depends on
these arguments and there is also this
unique identifier built in this is to
trick create to distinguish the
different handles that we are manually
compiling because otherwise it will just
merge those of them that textually match
together because it has a compilation
cash so here's how example the scent
that sends a message X to the object and
this is the message + send to an object
so and linking as i said is just storing
the handler which is our closure into
the global variable with a given name
very simple and we are now only three
times slower so we regained like a
factor of thousand and performance
success and the reason why we are slow
if we look in the intermediate
representation of the code that we got
from running this benchmark is that v8
went completely berserk with numerics
basically iteration variable that was
integer in the quad loop became suddenly
a double and it's constantly baktun
unbox consuming all our performance so
it's because we have a single congestion
point for numeric steal it's this
function that we patched into the
prototype of the number and all the
operations with numbers be they integers
or doubles they go in through the single
congestion point how do we solve it well
we already learned how we can solve the
same tissue we just need to put this end
into the handler so we need to put this
arithmetic into the handler specialized
the handler for the arithmetic we change
the template in a way that it now does
the check before it does the operation
and if it the check failed it goes and
handles it somewhere else in a
site-specific way ha so for numbers the
check is obvious you just need to check
that the left side and the right hand
side of the operation is a number and if
it is we just perform the operation in
the fast way instead of even you
in the call on the message so this is
how the scent of operation less than now
looks like a whiskey check left side
right side if there are numbers you just
return the result of this operation
otherwise you go into the mists case and
now we are only twenty five percent
slower so we solved most of the
performance issues that we had and the
twenty-five percent thing might be
scaring you but actually when you look
in the code that we had produced you see
the picture is nice and actually better
than I expected when I was testing this
because these things that are gray on
the picture I actually the false cases
of type of equals equals number
comparisons v8 was able to figure out
that certain things are definitely
numbers so all our Miss cases are
unreachable and optimized away so we are
good the hope is back maybe we can run
small talk efficiently on the JavaScript
engine however the bad part is the
semantics is still broken if I try to
send this message that I was trying to
send in the beginning I discovered that
undefined is not a function this is
universal truth and mmm however this
universal truth doesn't apply to small
talk because there is no undefined there
something is still worked in the scheme
of dynamic programming languages how can
we solve that well we know how we can
solve it we can say which message
messages the vector understands it
understands x.x call an eager why why
call and so on and i'm using echo script
six features because Sigma script 6
which is a cool like set so however we
don't know how to rewrite the handler we
want to have a check and then we want to
send the message directly but you don't
know what we can check we can check for
example something like this we can ask
the constructor of the receiver whether
it has this set and it understands the x
and then we call X so it looks
reasonable however it is very hard for
v8 to optimize because it doesn't see
the connection between the constructor
of an object and the fact that it has
this set and the fact that this set is
actually mutable there is no way to tell
it that this set is a mute
so it can't optimize that however one
thing that we it can do efficiently is
the load constructor from an object if
it already knows the objects hidden
class so we just will compare the
constructor of an object with some value
and then do a message sent directly but
unlike with a number case we don't know
with what to compare ahead of time when
we bootstrap the handler for the hour
send side so we need to obtain this
value somewhere as our program runs and
the way we can do it is we can remember
that we can relink call site as a our
sin side as the program executes and
this is where the power of this system
with sin sites adapting to the things
they see comes from so the solution is
to put strap and initialized handler and
then relink it when we miss so the
bootstrap function is now very simple
it's just always misses it always goes
to this site that means thing and
because the check is specified to be
false then when we miss in the Miss case
we can check if the constructor has the
understanding and the understand
declares that this object understands
this message then we can compile a
specialized handler for this particular
constructor and link it into this site
otherwise you throw this nice message
that says this object does not
understand this message okay the
template now looks something like that
so we have the constructor captured as a
closure variable in the tender itself
and we compare the constructor against
it and we send the message directly nice
and efficient you will say however we
just lost all of the performance that we
previously gained somehow so something
in our calculations was wrong and the
thing that was wrong there was our
assumption that we ate will behave nice
and tight with us but it really decided
that it doesn't want to inline the
handlers for us anymore after we're a
link them that's because the v8 has
these guys built in the
run around and try to figure out what
your program is actually doing and how
to optimize it however they're not only
smart enough so we need to help them be
smarter stop how much I'm so I went into
the source code of the v8 and this is
not JavaScript the C C++ and I found
that there is a heuristic which checks
whether the function that we are trying
to in line is an old function so it
survived a lot of garbage collections
and if it is then it is worth it to in
line otherwise it is not worth it
because it potentially can change it was
just created so I just treat this
heuristic to be very smart and if the
name of the global variable starts with
the Greek letter Sigma Capital then we
in line no matter what a great solution
I'm not going to submit this page to v8
because it's unlikely that it will be
accepted though I think it's cool
because nobody also calls their
functions with a Greek letter Sigma in
the beginning so it will be a fine
heuristic and with this we regained then
excellent in terms of the performance
because now we in line the handlers
however there is still a problem with
our code so i can sumption that the boss
left hand side and the right hand side
of the comparison that we use in the
check are constants and it is true for
the self dot constructor expression we
it was able to figure out that it is a
constant however the constructor
variable that is captured in the context
of the handler closure is not a constant
it just loaded from the context and the
context itself is a constant so he
strange the tree it did not fall these
things together so i took my precision
hammer again and i went into v8 again
and then i edit these lines of code they
just say if the variable that is in the
context is never assigned after it was
initialized and the context itself is no
during compilation time then we can just
load it in the compilation time because
it is totally it's true that it will
never change and then you can use it as
constant constant yes otherwise you just
do the normal load and we are almost
there where we want it to be we're only
twenty-five percent slower again and you
can implement the ad thing so there's a
thing we set is that you want to check
bounced when you do the scent of add to
the array you also don't want to patch
array prototype anymore so you can use
it the same techniques to produce a
specialized handler for the ad Colin
send and even if after you do it you
still will be only twenty-five percent
slower so you don't lose any performance
so we are good we're perfect and the
semantics is now correct if I try to
send this dot colon message to the
vector I get the nice error that object
n doesn't understand x and if i try to
access the array out of bounds and like
in javascript where you get the
undefined and then undefined is not a
function you get a nice error you can
ask me where are those twenty five
percent and i could spend another talk
trying to explain where they're coming
from basically their deficiencies in the
compilation pipeline but the timer here
is very scary so i will not do that so
if i use the hammer long enough then
they can regain almost all of it by
hacking in various parts of the v8
basically it's the register allocator
issues and various optimizations and i'm
positive that you can regain even more
you just need to use a bigger hammer and
it's actually depends on the cpu because
they produced code i looked at it in the
disassembler it's almost the same but is
for this hot look that I cooked for this
before for this talk and then when I ran
it on different machines it behaves
differently for example on my
workstation at work it is roughly the
same performance with the baseline
version so during the course of this
talk you should have figured out the
JavaScript itself is an invoke dynamic
one big invoke dynamic and we have
enough expressivity in the language that
to actually solve these problems what we
don't have enough of these optimizations
so their VMS are almost there
not entirely there because well they're
not completely optimized for this use
case of compiling the dynamic
programming languages into the
JavaScript so we want to get rid of the
heuristics that govern this inlining and
specialization and so on and we want to
have a set of conventions so invoke
dynamic for javascript is just a set of
conventions that would guarantee that
the certain functions are always in line
on all virtual machines that run
JavaScript and so on and we will use
those conventions to squash all these
cockroaches like slipper you use when
you want to squash cockroaches and
actually the oldest presentation is
alive because there is a much harder
thing to compile in smalltalk which is
the non-local return but well let's for
the next time so thank you for your
attention